foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the view from 22
I'm John Connolly The Spectators news
editor today we're talking about the
planned Ukrainian counter-offensive
against Russia and joining me to discuss
is Dimitri alparovich National Security
expert and co-founder of the Silverado
policy accelerator
hi Dimitri thank you for joining us now
we've been hearing about for a long time
now about a planned Ukrainian
counter-offensive uh the idea being that
after holding the Russians back
throughout the winter Ukraine could now
begin potentially to push back and try
and take back some of that land um so
what's the situation looking like there
at the moment in eastern Ukraine
well very likely this offensive has
already begun and I think a lot of
people have had uh unreasonable
expectations about this offensive
they've been thinking that this would be
sort of a lightning strike similar to
what the ukrainians did last year and
the Heart cable blessed in the north
where within a couple of days they were
able to get thousands of square
kilometers of territory and that's just
not going to be the case very likely
it's much more likely that this is going
to be more like the her song Campaign
which lasted many months which was a
highly nutritional fight with a lot of
artillery shaping campaigns against
Russian forces and uh very slow uh
progress until they were able to finally
kick the Russians out the Russians are
expecting of course this
counteroffensive they've been preparing
for it they've been building defensive
fortifications so what the ukrainians
are doing right now is really shaping
operations you see some minor operations
that they're doing near bahmoud and
those are likely to uh an attempt to
distract Russian forces maybe to bring
some reinfor enforcements from other
areas where the ukrainians are much more
likely to strike
it seems a bit like we've seen the
ukrainians playing down a bit some of
the counter-offensive talk I mean the
land we're talking about here it's about
the size of the UK that Russia still
holds in Ukraine I mean how much how
much of that do you think they could
really take back
well look I think it all depends on how
prepared they are but also it all
depends on how prepared the Russians are
um in fact when you look at the
successes that the cranes have had thus
far whether it was in the Battle of Kiev
whether it was in the uh Battle of
harkib whether it was the Battle of her
song Those successes and I don't want to
take anything away from the bravery and
the Brilliance of the Ukraine forces but
they were largely a result of the
Russians being willfully unprepared for
the fight in kivobles they they didn't
have Logistics they didn't have the
forces to take Kiev they have to
withdraw and heart to Robles they were
severely undermanned and the ukrainians
saw that and took advantage of that and
of course in our song they were on the
other side of the river the ukrainians
were able to blow their Bridges and they
were not able to supply their forces
those easy wins are gone now so the
Russians are much better prepared but
again if they make major strategic
mistakes if they fall for trap the
ukrainians May set for them and redirect
their forces and weaken their front
lines and the ukrainians are going to be
able to make some major gains and we
sold the announcement last week that the
UK are sending long-range missiles to
Ukraine I think the shadow missile
system they're called which have an even
longer range I mean do you think that
kind of thing can make a difference
I think it's certainly going to help uh
one of the things that the Russians have
done fairly well in recent months is
they've adjusted to the high Mars
weapons that the long-range rocket
launch systems that the US have provided
last summer uh by pushing back their
Logistics hubs outside of the range of
high Mars now those Logistics are once
again in range with the storm Shadows
being provided by the UK but the issue
with the storm Shadows is it's a very
expensive system over 700
000 per missile and there are relatively
few of them so the ukrainians are going
to need to be very thoughtful about the
targets they choose to hit
um and uh make sure that they're really
going to be able to hit the right
targets with those missiles because they
just don't have enough of them and
there's a story in the Washington post
as well saying that zelenski is perhaps
considering strikes inside the merchant
Mainland I mean do you think that's
something that we might see
well the the ukrainians have clearly
been striking the the Russian
um uh positions uh back in Russia for
quite some time now and I'm fairly
convinced that the Drone attack on the
Kremlin uh a few weeks ago was was not a
false flag operation was a grain
operation we've seen a number of other
drone strikes by the ukrainians against
uh Russian forces Russian airfields not
just in Crimea and other occupied
territories but in Russia itself
um that's going to continue uh but
zielinski has committed to the US and
the Allies that he will not use Western
weapons to do so so I think he's likely
to hold to that promise and when zonski
was in the UK he mentioned as well she'd
add that he's very keen to have some
Jets
um which the UK supported off and even
if not giving them individually I mean
do you think do you think that air
support could make the difference and do
you think he's likely to get them
so the key question about the Jets um
and the ukrainians clearly need them
because
um the the Russian uh Soviet era makes
that they're flying right now uh are
outgunned by the Russians um they uh are
also very stressed they've been flying
them in very uh stressful missions very
low to the ground so those airframes are
really getting worn out now they've
gotten some more uh mix from Eastern
European countries or uh formerly part
of the the Warsaw blocks so that's going
to help but they really need Western uh
jatson rather sooner rather than later
uh there's been a lot of talk around
about f-16s
um and their challenges where they have
16s it's a complicated jut to do
logistics for it requires relatively
proceed runways there's questions about
which missiles you can fit in on f-16s
that the US would actually be willing to
export and potentially have China
reverse engineer those missiles and and
impact their redness in the indo-pacific
a much better jet would be the Saab
Griffin from Sweden Sweden doesn't have
a lot of them but Czechoslovakia has a
number of them that they could
potentially donate if they get other
Jets to compensate like the f-16s and
they're trying to buy the F-35 so maybe
there's an opportunity to accelerate
that that would be a much better jet but
they need something because the reality
is that the air defenses that they have
are getting stressed to their limits the
number of interceptors that they have
um is also running out so you really
need to make sure that the Russians do
not establish air superiority over the
Skies of Ukraine and jets are going to
be critical to that do you think that's
something they need for this particular
summer offensive or do you think it's
more a long long-term concern well I I
thought that they needed it yesterday uh
not necessarily for the summer offensive
because the reality is you're not going
to have ukrainians really have effective
supportive Ground Forces with these Jets
just like the Russians have not been
able to do so in their campaigns because
the country is littered on both sides
with very effective air defenses so the
goal of the Jets is is not necessarily
to support land forces but to keep the
Russians from establishing air
superiority over the Skies of Ukraine to
keep the Russian Air Force at bay that's
really the main thing that you're trying
to accomplish there
um so far they still have some air
defenses
um operational and obviously the
Patriots and the nasams that have come
in from the West are helpful there as
well they're using a lot of them to
intercept these missiles that are
targeting Kiev and other cities so
that's the main issue that they have to
decide where to put those air defenses
do you put them closer to the front line
do you put them near the cities where
some strategic and civilian targets are
getting hit by the Russians it's a
really tough dilemma for them and that's
where the Jets can help and stepping
back for a second do you think there's a
bit of a risk here with the
counter-offensive in Ukraine in that if
they don't make the gains that perhaps
their Western allies have expected that
there might in turn be less Western
support in future because they'll be
thinking why should we send weapons to a
to a campaign that's not working do you
think do you think that's troubling uh
zielinski and other leaders in Kiev
I think that one of the things that
Putin is absolutely counting on is that
the West both the United States and
European allies are going to get tired
of this campaign they're going to run
out of stocks of Munitions to supply to
the ukrainians
um in the time of austerity measures
once again uh in the United States
there's going to be less appetite to uh
send tens of billions of dollars to
Ukraine and
um I think that that position is going
to be even more prominent if the
ukrainians Do Not uh show some major
gains on the front line it's a terrible
position that they're in uh but the
reality is that if the campaign grounds
grinds to hold the aid will not
necessarily disappear will never go to
zero but the big packages that they've
been getting up to this point uh will
likely uh start dwindling to to nothing
and we should talk a little bit about
the Russian side of this because this
week we've seen a remarkable story in
the Washington Post which said that you
have any progression uh the head of the
Wagner mercenary service according to
leaks from U.S intelligence was speaking
to the ukrainians about and offering to
give them Russian troop positions in
exchange for them removing troops from
back mood to where his mercenaries are
fighting I mean what did you make of
that story do you think it do you think
it's credible or what what did you make
of it well you know I won't comment on
classified information I'm not privy to
um whether that is true or not but I'll
tell you this that a certainly provision
uh is playing his own game here he
doesn't necessarily care about uh
Russian regular forces he wants to get
victories under his belt in Ukraine
itself
um the price for him is taking bahmoud
uh which you know by and large he's
already mostly taken he's got maybe a
dozen or so buildings left to take that
the ukrainians are still defending in
the city he wants to take that so that
he can go back to Putin and say see I'm
the only one that is actually victorious
in this campaign uh the regular forces
led by John garasimov the head of the
general staff and sure the defense
Minister are screwing up they're losing
territory I'm gaining territory and use
that as an opportunity to try to gain
more power inside Russia maybe he has
his own desires on the running Ministry
of Defense one day although I don't
think it's very realistic but um that's
what that that's the play that he's uh
uh orchestrating here so I'm not
surprised that he'll be willing to sell
anyone and everyone to try to accomplish
that I mean if if that report is
credible what do you think Putin would
make of that well that reporter is
already getting discredited in the
Russian media so I think that Putin is
just going to assume that this is U.S
propaganda so I don't think it's going
to impact the Goshen at all in his
position in Russia and one of
precautions earlier complaints was that
the defense Ministry in particular
wasn't supplying him with enough
ammunition has that kind of been
resolved now do you think
he's still complaining about it but I'll
tell you uh talking to the ukrainians on
the ground and back mood
um they're getting hit by a lot of
artillery systems uh a lot of Munitions
and shells coming down on their
positions so um regards you may be
complaining and he may want more but
they're already outgunning ukrainians uh
you know three or four to one uh in
terms of the the artillery shells that
they're firing so uh you know uh they
still have quite a quite a lot and
bakmut is largely a destroyed City right
now this is not unlike the regular uh
type of warfare that Russia conducts if
you look at gross name chachnia the
capital of chachnia uh was completely
leveled to the ground in the early 2000s
of course cities in Syria like Aleppo
have been destroyed by Russian bombing
strikes so they're just uh replaying
that old Playbook yeah I mean I mean it
feels I think a few months ago there was
a lot of talk a lot of worry and concern
from the West that Ukraine was expanding
to me lives and and resources defending
back mood um do you do you still agree
with that kind of assessment do you
think they maybe should have have Let It
Go and Consolidated us elsewhere or or
do you think they've been successful at
holding the Russians off until now
well look I think it's really hard to
criticize them on these tactical
decisions because they're there we are
not they have to make the decisions that
are right for them we don't have the
complete information and the other
element of this is that let's say they
withdrew from back mode um they would
still have to fight the Russians
somewhere so they would still face the
attrition that they're experiencing on
their own forces on their own uh
Munitions so
um whether it's bakmud or something else
that fight would still go on so turning
now to sort of the bit of the Russian
strategy
um over the summer what are their main
names now is it just to kind of hold the
lines or do you think they'd be hoping
to push push the ukrainians elsewhere
yeah this this is a little bit like just
now where each side gets to play move
and then wait for the other side to
respond so the Russians have had their
offensive which really hasn't gained
them much at all uh maybe they'll finish
it by taking those few remaining uh
buildings in bakmud probably destroying
them uh and then they'll uh sit and wait
and and respond to the Ukrainian
counter-attack
um depending on how successful the
ukrainians are that could either change
everything or uh you know get us back
into a position where maybe some
territory changed but uh fundamentally
uh the Strategic position of both sides
has not changed
um and then Putin will have a decision
to make because he does not have the
forces right now to launch another
counter offensive and uh to do so he
will have to do another major
mobilization drives uh clearly something
that he has been resistant to do and
something that has real political cost
to him but he's also very committed to
this fight so I would not put it past
them sometime this summer and the fall
to to actually call it up and one of the
things that he's got now is these laws
that have been passed by the Russian
Duma the Russian Parliament that make it
much easier for him to uh prevent draft
dodging and and to call up people uh
because now um they don't even have to
notify people in person they can do so
electronically through government
systems that they regularly interact
with and that gives them a lot more
flexibility so we've already had sort of
one round of Russian mobilization we've
also had most new groups like Wagner
using using prisoners and so in Ukraine
I mean how successful has that been for
Russia is it just sort of throwing
bodies at the problem and because
they've got a large population that can
get away with it you think or or has
there been some success to it well uh
there are different elements here I
think Wagner has actually been a more
effective force not necessarily because
of the convex that they've thrown at the
front line those have been basically uh
need to be to fell into the into the
grinder there but
um the rest of the Wagner is actually
fairly professionalized Force comprised
of uh foreign military personnel that
have had experience in Syria have had
experience in in Africa and Libya uh and
elsewhere and and previously in Ukraine
itself so um they've done fairly well
and the ukrainians actually have have
talked about how Wagner presents a major
challenge to them the mobilized uh
personnel and the regular army have done
much less well and uh in part because
the training has been very limited but
the ukrainians are facing the same
problem now the reality is that on both
sides now this is a war of the mobilize
the uh people with experience in in
warfighting on both sides have either
died or been wounded and taken out of
action and now you have people that
don't have that much experience on the
Ukrainian side they are sending people
to the west but it's only uh you know
four to six weeks of training it's not a
lot to train someone and to do combined
arms operations and if you're trying to
complex offensive operations I think
both sides are going to be challenged in
that area but defensive uh operations
are certainly much easier and I think
both sides still have capabilities there
presumably Ukraine must be more worried
than than Russia that if this character
offensive goes badly and they lose a lot
of men then they're going to really
struggle to replenish that because with
a small population right yeah I mean the
ukrainians still have millions of people
that they couldn't Coop as well but
certainly they have to worry about the
impact of their economy the economy has
experienced over 40 GDP decline in the
last year the Russian economy
experienced only two percent GDP decline
so
um they can't call up every able-bodied
uh man in Ukraine uh to the front line
because what is going to remain of their
economy so they have to be thoughtful
about this but this is really the
biggest problem for Ukraine right now is
that that people don't always appreciate
that Ukrainian Victory and Russian
Victory are two different things
entirely Russia doesn't have to win it
just needs to not lose and Ukraine
actually needs to win it needs to take
back the territory that is lost and and
kick Russia out and that's much much
harder to do than for the Russians to
try to hang on to what they've taken
well that brings us on nicely to my to
my final question which is that
um say if this counter-offensive isn't
it successful as as some I hope
um the lines that you know Russia's
lines don't get pushed back that much
they they hold on to a substantial
amount of Ukrainian territory
um do you think we're going to see
greater calls for Ukraine to come to the
negotiating table and and negotiate with
Russia
well you've already seen that you know
I'm here in Europe uh this week and uh
talking to Europeans uh across the
continent a lot of them are wondering
when is Ukraine going to start
negotiating the problem with that
position is that they don't have anyone
to negotiate with there's zero
indication that Putin is at all
interested in negotiating I think he's
certainly looking at the calendar
election calendar uh next year in the
United States where he makes back uh
potentially an Administration to come
um uh to power that that may be uh less
interested in helping Ukraine uh he's
also looking at the munition supplies in
the west or dwindling uh particularly
artillery and air defense interceptors
and is hoping that that's going to
change his uh his fortune so the idea
that he's going to make some major
concessions to Ukraine and negotiations
at this moment I think is a pipe dream
brilliant thank you very much Dimitri
thank you
[Music]